[Applause]
[Music]
august is here
and a new month means a bunch of new
releases to play that's the name of the
show
so we're gonna highlight some of the
hottest games launching all month long
and this time around you can get most of
them for free
first out of the gate is a game about
well being in first place
fall guy's ultimate knockout mixes party
games with some battle royale flavor
pitting 60 players against each other in
a fight for the top spot
think wipeout or ninja warrior but with
just one winner
fall guys is coming to ps4 and pc on
tuesday august 4th
and if you happen to be a ps plus member
good news you're getting it for free
this month
otherwise it'll cost you 20 bucks or 16
pounds
you can also race for first place in
fast and furious crossroads
this is a new chapter in the saga
starring dom letty and roman
all of whom are voiced by their proper
movie actors you'll be taking on an
international crime syndicate
pulling off all the ludicrous stunts
you've come to expect from the fast and
furious franchise
and of course you can compete against
other drivers online too
we might have to wait a while for the
next movie but this game pulls onto ps4
xbox one and pc on friday the 7th
if you prefer to fly instead of drive
then be on the lookout for microsoft
flight simulator
the fan favorite flight sim is back
letting you travel around the world
during the day and night in a variety of
weather conditions
you can take off and land at thousands
of different airports and fly over all
sorts of cities mountains deserts and
forests the world over
what's more the game will adapt to your
level of experience with extra guidance
as you glide around
microsoft flight simulator comes to pc
on tuesday the 18th
and game pass pc members can take off on
day one
here's hoping the airplane movie mods
come soon after
we have clearance clarence roger roger
what's our vector victor
that's not the only game making a
comeback this month either thanks to
final fantasy crystal chronicles
remastered edition
the gamecube classic is back with better
graphics new music arrangements
and even some fresh new dungeons what's
more you can explore those dungeons with
friends on other platforms thanks to
crossplay
that's coming to ps4 switch ios and
android on thursday the 27th
and you can try a demo the same day
it'll even let you check out the first
three dungeons with players who have the
full game
life is strange developer don't nod is
back with another narrative adventure
game called tell me why
it's about twins alison and tyler
dealing with childhood memories as they
return home
tyler a transgender man has transitioned
prior to the twins return home
and the game will explore his childhood
and the lead-up to his decision to do so
there are also some of your own
decisions to make choosing which of the
twins memories of the past to rely on
which will change how the story plays
out
episode 1 comes to xbox one and pc on
the 27th
and once again game pass members can try
it out on day one
otherwise you'll be shelling out 30
bucks for the full trilogy of episodes
there's no word on buying them
individually right now
and those are some of the hottest games
launching all month long
as always remember that release dates
are based on retailer listings and are
subject to change
thanks for watching everyone and i'll be
back with a closer look at more august
games
next sunday
[Music]